- (commentateur): On va ajouter
un petit peu de piquant, là.
- La rumeur de sa retraite
courait depuis quelques jours et
Tom Brady l'a confirmé mardi sur
les réseaux sociaux. Le quart-
arrière de 44 ans a choisi
d'accrocher ses crampons après
avoir réécrit une bonne partie
du livre des records de la NFL.
... a-t-il écrit dans
une enfilade de gazouillis.
(commentateur, en anglais)
- Brady se retire comme le
quart-arrière le plus accompli
de l'histoire de la NFL. Il a
fait sa renommée sous les ordres
de Bill Belichick avec
les Patriots de la Nouvelle-
Angleterre de 2000 à 2019,
remportant au passage six titres
du Super Bowl.
En 2020, il a quitté
cette équipe pour rejoindre
les Buccaneers de Tampa Bay avec
lesquels il a gagné son septième
et ultime Super Bowl à 43 ans.
... a déclaré le commissaire
Roger Goodell par
communiqué.
PIERRE VERCHEVAL, analyste de
football à RDS, ex-joueur
- C'est sûr que si on se fie
strictemiffres,iffres,iffres,if,
c'est facile; il a la majorité
des records comme passeur,
il a gagné sept Super Bowl.
Mais moi, ce que j'aime beaucoup
dans sa , c'est qu'il a
gagné en début de carrière,
en milieu de carrière, en fin
de carrière, donc longévité.
- Brady n'a jamais été
fort ou le plus rapide,
mais ce qui a fait son succès,
c'est son intelligence
sur le terrain, son habileté
à contrôler le cours d'un matche
jouer. Il a terminé à 44 ans
sa 22e saison, il l'a terminée
au premier rang pour les passes
complétées, les vergeset les pa.
C'est exceptionnel. Il se retire
vraiment au sommet de son art.
- Avec ses titres du Super Bowl
et ses innombrables records,
Brady est promis au Temple de
la renommée. Il devrait y faire
son entr première première preme
d'admissibilité en 2026.
Mais dans la mémoire collective,
il fait déjà partie des grands
parmi les grands.
Raphaël Guillemette,
Radio-Canada, Montréal